As we said, our plan is to
have the victims contact us.
That is, after we spread a malware,
each victim computer, or
compromised computer,
will somehow contact us.
For example, we may hardcode in the
malware some email address that we use
or even our IP address and so on.
The first problem with such approach of
hardcoding our content information in
the malware so that the victims can
contact us, is that it is not stealthy.
It is a safe bet, that eventually,
security admins will find out that
there are bots on their network and
they may be able to obtain
the botcode or the malware.
And through malware analysis,
they may be able to recover
our hardcoded address.
>From there, they can identify us,
so this is not stealthy at all.
The second problem is that,
this is not robust at all,
because there's only one single
server for command control.
That's the one that's
hardcoded in the malware.
For example, if we have hardcoded our
email address in the malware, and
the email address
account has been banned,
then there is no command control
available for victims anymore.
So this is not robust.